[Musik]
ein wunderschön dieser film macht alles
richtig
fast alles guten tag kommen sie rein
[Musik]
der junge muss an die frische luft sind
die kindheitserinnerungen von hape
kerkeling die auch schon als buch
veröffentlicht hat
eigentlich ist es ein heimatfilm das
liegt daran dass es eben eine
persönliche erinnerung ist und in dieser
persönlichen erinnerungen sind
eigentlich alle menschen gut die
großeltern sind mit beide seiten der
vater ist gut wenn auch nicht viel da
der große bruder ist gut der junge
selbst ist gut für mich nicht darum was
die leute sagt den jungen kann später
spielt julius weg auf und er macht das
wirklich bahn sind muss obwohl noch gar
nicht getauscht hat
aber hat genau dieses dieses gefühl von
sentimentalität manchmal und tiefgang
und totalem humor also er macht dann
eben gerne leute nach aus der
nachbarschaft und bringt alle zum lachen
das macht der junge wirklich super es
ist gar nicht langweilig es ist sehr
lustig und das ist natürlich auch sehr
traurig wir sehen
von luise heyer ganz toll gespielt wie
diese mutter die eigentlich eine
lebensfrohe ist immer bedrückter wird
immer trauriger wird sie ist krank und
der kleine junge versucht eben immer sie
aufzumuntern und es gelingt ihm auch
immer wieder und die zuschauer munterten
mit
anlass ist aber auch stehe hier drin
wird wird man ja sowas dann trieb sie
nicht sehen wir das nicht länger haben
der junge fußballer hat die frische luft
es geht ihr nicht gut willi da kann er
aber nichts dafür
[Musik]
ich musste relativ lange nach dem film
darüber nachdenken was nicht so richtig
mit ihm stimmt weil es nicht sofort ins
auge fällt aber es gibt ein
perspektivspieler
es ist eigentlich ja aus der sicht von
hape kerkeling sind seine erinnerungen
und es gibt auch seine stimme aus dem
off aber viel zu selten das heißt es
wird dargestellt als wäre es die
realität gewesen aber sind natürlich
ganz subjektive erinnerungen und deshalb
hat man auch dieses gefühl eines
heimatfilms und dieses gefühl dass alle
gut sind und das ist zwar natürlich
schön anzusehen aber das hinterlässt ein
sonderbares gefühlen denn er weiß was er
will später dann man hat einfach
[Musik]